Das ist unser Hotel.
Es sieht toll aus!
Ja, ich freue mich schon auf unseren Aufenthalt.
Wir werden uns schön entspannen können.
Lass uns reingehen.
An der Rezeption machen wir den Check-In.
Danach können wir in unser Zimmer gehen.
Das hört sich gut an.
Guten Tag.
Wir haben eine Reservierung.
Mein Name ist Pascal.
Guten Tag und herzlich willkommen.
Ich schaue kurz im System nach.
Genau. Sie bleiben 2 Nächte bei uns.
Ist das richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Sehr gut.
Ich sehe, dass Sie
bereits mit der Karte bezahlt haben.
Somit können Sie gleich ins Zimmer gehen.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Hier haben Sie Ihre Schlüssel.
Sie sind im Zimmer Nummer 302.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Aufenthalt.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin müde von der Reise.
Ich freue mich auf mein Bett.
Hoffentlich ist es bequem.
Ja, ich bin auch müde.
Lass uns doch 30 Minuten erholen.
Danach können wir ins Fitnesszentrum gehen.
Ich muss heute noch Sport machen.
Ja, das hört sich gut an.
Sport nach einer Reise ist eine großartige Idee.
Nach dem Sport möchte ich aber zum Pool gehen.
Bist du einverstanden?
Ja, genau das wollte ich dir auch vorschlagen!
Wow, das Zimmer sieht wunderschön aus.
Hier werde ich super schlafen können.
Ja, es ist modern und gross.
Es gefällt mir sehr.
Ich möchte mich jetzt hinlegen.
Danach können wir ins Fitnesszentrum gehen.
Genau. Lass uns kurz schlafen.
Danach können wir Sport machen.
Ok, das können wir machen.
*30 min später*
Wow, das hat aber gutgetan.
Ich fühle mich jetzt viel fitter.
Du auch?
Ja, mir geht es viel besser.
Ich könnte jetzt aber noch länger schlafen.
Du Faulpelz!
Zieh dich um, jetzt gehen wir Sport machen!
Jaja, ist schon gut.
Ich bin in 5 Minuten bereit.
Ich ziehe mich jetzt um.
Super. Ich ziehe mich auch um.
Ich bin müde.
Ich werde heute nur 30 Minuten trainieren.
Das reicht mir.
Ja, das reicht mir auch.
Ichmöchte nur auf dem Laufband rennen.
Danach mache ich noch einige Übungen.
Genau. So habe ich mir das auch vorgestellt.
*15 Minuten später*
Ich bin kaputt.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich höre auf für heute.
Morgen komme ich wieder.
Ich bin auch fix und fertig.
Vor dem Training zu schlafen war keine gute Idee.
Egal, lass uns duschen gehen.
Danach gehen wir zum Pool.
Wow, der Pool ist ja riesig!
Das wird toll!
Ja, und die Aussicht ist atemberaubend.
Schau dir mal die Stadt an.
Ich bin so glücklich hier zu sein.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Wasser.
Dort kann ich mich entspannen.
Das hört sich gut an.
Ich komme auch ins Wasser.
Danach will ich auf dem Liegestuhl sonnenbaden.
Uff, das Wasser ist aber frisch.
Ich muss wieder raus.
Ich will mich in der Sonne aufwärmen.
Du bist ein Weichei.
Das Wasser ist toll!
Ich bleibe nochein bisschen.
*einige Stunden später*
Ich habe Lust auf Cocktails!
Dieser Urlaub ist toll.
Und diese Aussicht bei Nacht – unbezahlbar!
Es freut mich zu sehen, dass es dir gefällt.
Es ist wirklich grossartig hier.
Ich möchte eine Margarita trinken.
Da bin ich dabei.
Ich möchte auch eine Margarita trinken.
Guten Abend. Was darf es für Sie sein?
Bitte 2 Margaritas.
Vielen Dank.
2 Margaritas, kommt sofort.
Das ist eine tolle Art, um den
Abend ausklingen zu lassen.
Cocktails in einer Rooftop Bar.
Das sollten wir häufiger machen.
Ich bin einverstanden.
Dafür müssen wir nicht in den Urlaub gehen.
Wir können auch zu Hause das Leben geniessen.
Hier haben Sie Ihre Margaritas.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin schon müde.
Lass uns die Margaritas
trinken.
Danach gehen wir schlafen.
Morgen schauen wir uns Berlin an!
Das hört sich perfekt an.
Morgen sind wir wieder fit und munter.
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule.
Aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben.
Klicke auf diese Playlist
um weitere Videos zu sehen.